how
how did you feel
how did you feel
when you um
you eased up and you were you opened up
emotionally ever so slightly terrible
see
opening up emotionally doesn't really
and i would i would go as far as to
assume this is how all men work
opening up emotionally does not solve
the problem it just gives another person
leverage to then criticize you about how
you're reacting to the problem so but
then you're ripped the wrong guy i mean
well the wrong person
because
so do you think that a woman can take on
a man's problems
no i don't
correct me if i'm wrong i don't think
when a woman is telling you like to to
open up this so that she can take on
your burden or
or
or whatever i don't i don't think that's
the case for me personally um and again
i might be
um an exception to the rule and paul
hates the exception still
but my ex she's she's a feminist right
and which ex
you
know shots fired
um
she's the ironic thing she's american as
well
might be watching this um
yeah but she's um she's a feminist and
um when
it
i grew up very much like i would say
most men to the point where where you
know we're trained to be this alpha male
alpha present so with a lot of the time
i wouldn't i'll be going through things
and i wouldn't speak out about it
and yeah it did come to the point where
it's like yo like why like what is it
like why don't you you know you speak
out more about about what it is
and it was hard for me because i wasn't
trained to do that but then
it's i tried it with one fact i just
said something and it was something that
was hurting me for a long long time
you know some some trauma that i had
went through uh as a young person um so
when i said that
it
it
for my relationship anyways it helped us
because it removed some of the
the the frictions in communication and
she was able to understand me better
because of what i said because i would
just be reacting to things and she
wouldn't really know where it stemmed
from
so so
but you realize the original problem is
you weren't in control of your emotions
to begin with
because you were reacting to things and
then she was noticing yeah but i wasn't
reacting
in the best way right right but that's
that's like where it started from though
the problem is you not controlling your
emotions to begin with right did who did
you break up with her did she break up
with you
we both
did she break up with you
like that honestly you started the
conversation honestly we had uh i'm a
kabul mutual breakup it's never it's
never mutual did you cheat no no
but we we really did have a namical
mutual
uh breakup
was it your idea
but it was both of us that's not the
point no if it wasn't your idea
you didn't initiate in your mind
understand
she may have made you think it was that
it was legitimate
probably
it wasn't that it wasn't that at all i
think with me it all stems from what i'm
saying i probably would was thinking
about it but never i never like
vocalized it so then the relationship
become became toxic and with me and her
we were friends like before so we all we
always agree that we'll protect the
friendship when it was coming to the
point where the relationship was
was becoming slightly toxic because of
what i wasn't you know what i was
harboring and overthinking in my head it
came to a point was just like yo where
are we going with this we need to call
it but we're cool i spoke to her today
she's cool
so you're still friends yeah yeah
um so she kind of like friend zoned you
a little bit
um
well yeah
yeah she she kind of did well that's
that's what we do to guys that are too
emotionally available
nah
nah
[Music]
but the reason the reason why we broke
up wasn't because i was too emotionally
available you you might
that you want to do a um on youtube
no no i don't have to do a poll because
i ask though we we we speak um
we speak and
um yeah it wasn't that wasn't that
wasn't the reason so
but again that might that might just be
an exception um i don't think it's like
that with most men and most women
um but it just taught my pain was it
just taught me a lot that being um and
don't get me wrong i don't i'm not so
emotional that i'll cry uncontrollably
that's not that's not what i'm saying
but i do feel like um
as men will talk to kind of keep our
emotions in but if we bring it out it
does have benefits well but here's the
thing there's a difference between a guy
who's very strong yeah and you know cry
like maybe you see him like okay my dad
is someone i really respect like i
respect my dad more than anyone right
and i've seen him cry twice in my life
but it's like one thing when a guy's a
strong like masculine man and like okay
then he cries
versus like someone that's
not in control of their emotions or
unemotion or um crying all the time and
the point is by and large in general
women prefer
men that are
emotionally unavailable yeah but the
person that cries all the time that
like even if he claims to be a feminist
removing his feminism he has a personal
issue that he has to deal with way but
the point is that women are telling men
that they would prefer someone that's
emotionally available which just by and
large isn't true like there are studies
that show that if a woman sees a guy cry
she's less attracted to him
and it's not fun like that doesn't make
women look good
like that's kind of that's kind of an
[ __ ]
but it's just you can't deny it if
there's studies that show this i feel
like there's different ways of
expressing feelings though like you can
express feelings and just break down and
cry and be a complete mess or you can
literally just be like oh by the way
like
my cousin something happened to my
cousin so i'm feeling a bit down
that's it that's like maybe enough to
express yeah and then the woman or the
partner can be like oh i understand i'll
be a bit nicer blah blah that's way
different than the guy just crying and
like
i don't know maybe attacking her because
he's in a state like this kind of thing
different way who are these guys i i do
not know of men oh no these are
hypothetical i don't know oh right i
don't think anyway let's talk toxic
no guys that that cry on control of me
that's right that was more of an
experience
like it's common dude these guys are
normally found really yeah i've had a
lot of friends the most manipulative men
are the ones who really ride on this
like
i should be allowed to be emotional
don't shame me for crying
etc um yeah
i'm not around and in those
relationships or a man
is the typical relationship you see
where a man is more in touch with his
feminine side is usually the woman
that's more of a leader and taking
reigns on the whole relationship
and um and she hates him
yeah she'll be like he hates him yeah
yeah lucky and she's sleeping with
tyrone on the side
why am i cousin tyrone
chad tyrone
i do i i did find it quite interesting
you touched on um
an interesting point there where when
people say men should be more emotional
i think men and women hear different
things
so
guys men who you know like yourself who
say that i'm a male feminist kind of
hear
manage your emotions in an adult way
and then women
other people think of like being
emotional and i think men have always
managed their emotions you know people
went to war had trauma men have always
relied on each other supported each
other um you know there's been therapy
in a lot of different ways i think this
idea that like men are these you know
stoic beings who never deal with their
emotions in any way is a bit of an
exaggeration it's used to push this idea
of like being overly weak and emotional
to combat this already extreme kind of
starting point which is not really
consistent with actual reality